vous devez traverser 12 pieds de
béton et 70 000 gallons d'
eau sous pression sans métal ni
réservoirs d'oxygène Benji se tient prêt à recevoir
Ethan prêt point important si vous avez
une trappe ouverte après deux minutes et demie
nous sommes tous les deux morts non non  non
même à bord whoa whoa tu es d'accord pour
me conduire il y a une minute tu étais mort de quoi
tu parles ça ne va pas gagner
bien
mr.  président, le moment est venu de
dissoudre le FMI, ce n'est pas seulement une
organisation voyou, c'est une organisation déshonorée de
fermer le FMI comme une erreur, vous
pouvez regretter Brett, un syndicat est réel
et ils savent qui vous êtes une nation de corde
formée pour faire ce que nous faisons  et tante FMI
ils viennent après nous avec tout ce
qu'ils ont
oh mec tu veux faire tomber le
syndicat c'est impossible de prendre ta
position qui est sur le point de
commencer bonsoir l'équipe répondra
pour chaque impact de chaos que tu veux  sommes
responsables pour l'instant nous sommes tous 12 par la
CIA génial
c'est peut-être notre dernière mission faisons
un décompte
pour cette porte maintenant oh mon dieu
vous